Speaker 1: We found another guy with tears in
his eyes. Republican Senator Lindsey Graham,
who has debased himself humiliatingly over the
last six years, was tearing up on Fox News last
night. It does not get much better than this. Here
is Lindsey crying about Trump's indictment. Wow.
Speaker 3: How do you do it? You take a well, if
you got a pile of crap and he chop it up 34 times
is still a pile of crap. Is duplicitous charging.
Speaker 1: I think by duplicitous him means
duplicitous or duplicative. It's
very unclear what he's talking about,
but he is all teary about crap.
Speaker 3: Is duplicitous charging.
They're trying to smear the guy. They're trying
to take cases that nobody else would take and
resurrect them. This is literally legal voodoo.
Speaker 1: Folks. If I really hope that this is
the first of many indictments, I really do.
If Lindsey is this broken up and triggered by
the first one, which is arguably the most
minor one, what's happening in Georgia is
potentially far more disastrous for Trump
than this. Just you wait until we get to
the next one. So Lindsey not having a good
one. Let's briefly talk now about Eric Trump.